-So happy to have you here.
-Thank you.
It's so nice to be back here.
-I saw you recently,
and we were talking about --
You have a baby. Kit.
-I have a baby.
-How is Kit doing?
-Kit is doing great.
She's 5 months old.
-Fantastic.
-And actually,
I've been living in New York
for a couple months now.
-There you go.
-Thank you. Yes.
And one of the things --
You were so kind.
You and your wife Alexi
were so kind.
You recommended a doctor.
-Yeah.
-And she's an amazing doctor.
-She's great.
-For my child.
And so I went in with her
to get her shots,
and one of the --
This is a cool doctor,
'cause the first thing she said
to me, she was like,
"Hi. Just so you know,
I don't watch any TV."
[ Laughter ]
And to me, of course,
that meant, like,
it was like a challenge to me.
-Yeah.
-She's just not into -- I don't
know if she's said this to you.
Like, she's just like,
"I don't watch any TV."
-But I have to say,
if she says that,
like, she's watched a little.
-She's watched a little TV.
-To know that that's something
she needs to tell you.
-Yeah.
And instead of being like,
"Okay, this is about my
daughter and getting her shots,"
I was like, "Now I gotta impress
this woman."
And so I was like,
"No? You don't watch any TV?
What about films?"
[ Laughter ]
"Have you seen
'A Wrinkle in Time'?
I know Oprah."
And she's just like, "Truly, I
just need to give your daughter
a vaccination
to extend her life."
And I'm like, "But I was on
'The Office' with Steve Carell."
[ Laughter ]
And she just --
She just didn't care.
But she's a good doctor.
-This is very exciting,
to be in this "Ocean's 8" film
with all these
incredible actresses.
-Yeah.
-And you guys famously are on
a text chain together.
-Yes.
-Do you guys still -- Is this
still an existing text chain?
-Well, we are on
a text chain together.
And then, what happened was
we have been talking
about the text chain.
So Nora -- Awkwafina,
who is in the movie -- was like,
"I think someone might hack
one of our phones."
-Right.
-"To get the information,"
which I thought was smart.
So we got --
She named some app
that we could have
another text chain.
But we had to, like,
come up with our fake names
on the text chain.
And some of us were...
just used their first name
because they're more mature.
And I was Sarahpaulsonfan69...
[ Laughter ]
...since Sarah Paulson
is in the movie.
And then she was manboob69.
So that's the level.
-Okay, that's the level
of discourse that's happening.
-Of discourse on this chain.
-You obviously,
for a big film like this,
you've had to do a ton of press.
-Yeah.
-How has that been?
-It's been mostly great
because the other actresses
are really fun.
And it's nice
to do press with them.
But today -- You know, so when
you're doing these heist movies,
everyone has, like,
their special power,
which is why Debbie Ocean, like,
pulls us together
to do this heist.
And so an interviewer,
this male interviewer --
We're doing international press.
He was -- I was doing press
with Anne Hathaway
and with Sarah Paulson.
And he was, like, was asking us,
like, Annie, she's an actress.
In the movie,
she plays an actress.
And Sarah Paulson,
she's a party promoter in it.
And then with me, she was like,
okay -- he was like,
"Mindy, you play a jeweler.
"Now you are not married
and have never been engaged.
So how do you know
about diamonds?"
[ Laughter ]
'Cause it's all about diamonds
and stealing diamond necklaces.
And I was like, "I'm sorry."
So he's basically like,
"How you, a famous spinster..."
[ Laughter ]
"How would you --
"You've never been anywhere near
a diamond before.
No man has ever --"
It's like as though
if you're not married
and engaged,
you've never seen a diamond.
You have -- And it was...
-It also seems to be
that he has a fundamental
misunderstanding of acting.
-Yes. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Because you could have
said like, "By the way,
none of us have robbed
a museum." Yeah.
-None of us
have robbed a museum.
But he was so incredulous.
-Yeah.
-He was like,
"I can't put this together.
"No man has ever loved you.
So in what way would you --"
I know. It was --
-That strikes me
as a very European
press question.
Like, "Yes, we do not -- We ask
the question we think of,
and you cannot take offense."
-Yes, without
giving away too much,
yes, that is a correct guess.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-You guys filmed at the museum,
at the Met at night.
Was that a cool scene,
to be filming there?
-Yes. A lot of the movie takes
place at a fake Met Gala.
And you've been there before...
-Yeah.
-...which is very glamorous.
So for most of the actresses,
they got to wear, like, gowns
and go to the fake Met Gala.
And when I heard about
the script, I thought,
"Oh, this is -- I love fashion,
I love the Met Gala."
But we were going through
the script,
and all of them are there,
and I am playing
a short order chef at the Met.
So I'm three floors down,
in, like, at the bowels of
the Met, like, washing dishes.
So without giving too much
spoiler alert, like, you know,
Sandy is looking so beautiful
and Anne Hathaway
is looking beautiful.
And they then they cut to me,
and I'm like --
I'm literally washing dishes.
And I have my earpiece.
And I'm like...
And then I have to go,
"Miguel, I'm going on my break!"
[ Laughter ]
And then I spend
the rest of the movie
in a large bathroom stall,
assembling a necklace.
-Yeah.
-So that's what I got to do.
[ Laughter ]
-But that made sense to me.
That makes sense to me because
you have been to a bathroom.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
So I understood this part.
This part makes sense.